now up on stream in the losers side we
have el padre el padre around a sheiks
the hero of Spain
indeed he felt the subatomic savers who
is on top of a winter side yesterday but
of course you can never count shanks out
as soon as he fell to the loser bracket
we all figured he was still a favourite
to make top aid still capable of making
grand finals and taking the whole
tournament but now he's got to go
through the kill saves I'm not sure how
the kill safe feels about this matchup
up against shanks but we're gonna see
how he's gonna play it so I feel like
shanks is gonna be trying to bring in
Broly - fuzzy his team has like a really
good option with Android 18 being able
to fuzzy and also adult go on adult
Gohan yeah Ken fuzzy so shanks is in a
good position there if he can definitely
get really early because that is one of
the kill stages strongest characters I
think Super Saiyan Goku is just Super
Saiyan Goku on his team it's nothing
special for her to kill Satan but his
main shell here to get rid of is his
team Gohan and the Broly yeah Goku acts
as the beam assist riot sounds very
strong but besides that the kill stages
Goku is not like something you have to
super worry about you have to worry
about just the powerup that all these
Goku players seem to get when he's the
last character alive but besides that
Chang should be fine
yep if you got to kill sage on this
let's see those to kill freaking sand
Chad and if you have el padre shakes
let's see you already know those Spanish
flags with the genki-dama and you
already know those being flooded in the
chat shanks we're gonna make top 8 here
does have to go through the loser side
to do it ins got to get through the kill
sage I like this foot here
eighty-nine point but he is playing go
on on point for this start of this match
probably because my assumption is
Android eight team relies so much on 17
assists it's probably harder for her to
get 17 assists that one they're square
but were you there for the teen gohan to
Laura through the live button in this
game kind of watch out for all the auto
combo stuff coming your way does block
the legs here I try to the cover of wow
I love that I love the paint from the DP
they're super awesome mark hit the kill
stage trying to punish him oh and then
punishes the reflect does do with 5l but
he's got enough meter on deck to kill
him regardless bring them down you have
dragon rush extension here make sure to
build the Octomom
meter before getting the kill and
bringing in Android 18 it's a little bit
safe for her to come out now now the
team go on is put to rest yeah and to
kill stage I mean he's got suit or
excuse me brawl he's got such a big
heart box right a 17 is most definitely
gonna be clipping up and I like the use
of the heavy 17 assists here not gonna
allow the kill team pull out that
weaknesses very smart
we're gonna snap in go for the 17
assists here the
medium supremacist early sparking here
from to kill sage know if this being a
free use right now or L here getting
blown up people cept it if he has to
yeah that's plenty because this was on
cooldown right so the girls name you
couldn't call it even if you wanted to
I know I just love it that's so can into
the show because there is the episode
where they're fighting and he says that
it'll let her fight Vegeta
but he'll step in if you have to yeah I
love it it's all good the way they
implemented I was getting little stuff
like that yeah they really think really
care the kill/save making some work here
of the level one gonna see level 3 he's
a smart one at the corner man he thought
he was gonna come out with a dragon rush
but now shanks max them in the mountains
at 5m good distance on that Android 18
5m stomp them down yes
can I get another level up yes potential
unholy
he is mystic right now completely absorb
the incident air - double axe handle
with the 18 assists again very excited -
shakes right now and if shanks does pull
this win one thing I would like to see
to kill safe but just who is that 18
barrier guard cancel that's unfortunate
for the kill sage her her light her
light is faster it used to be seven
frames and now it is six frames indeed
shakes offering all of the hand warmers
again we just saw him post something
cursed on Twitter it was like gamer goo
and it's like sweaty first sweaty hands
you saw reaching down right there trying
to keep the moisture off the hand nice
and dry it is a little humid here in
Puerto Rico yeah okay once ago the shank
Spain is probably destroying twitch chat
right now has extension with a brawling
be able taken to the corner here this is
a big problem for the kill station in
the first games in output as much damage
as possible
man okay yeah you kill sage making quick
work here rapido min tape Oh clips are
there yeah was so good you just
converter a full combo oh my goodness
put that 17 assists away yeah but it's
sweet I sleep
the dragon rush nice advantage from
shanks yeah I do like that managed got
him out of that corner positioning but
still have to deal with this tank man
all these raw things are going to
snuffed out and then become a house as
well
yeah thanks health is just dwindling
here not I think that loss of momentum
at the beginning has actually hurt
shakes pretty pretty decent here and
let's beginning of this game for sure we
got cute blasts on deck okay
yeah but with a double level one that
has a dead Gohan blowing through to
regen
yeah incredible start for the kill say
kid was really ask for a better one able
to kill off the Gohan and waste the
sparker chinks as well but where's the
signature Android 18 still available get
a level three good from chasing him but
that meter penalty not allowing him to
get the second bar what the very does
get in so good food shakes right there
cause the Android 17 out actually sparks
up sort of kills sage get some life back
[Music]
the characters and the kill sage now has
a bully back in as well big neutral
controlling this character right huge
bun good he blasts good projectile game
in general this is gonna be a big
comeback just with that grab that's
gonna do a little bit of damage here to
shanks this he has a lot of work to put
in if he wants to take this checking
game on to go save and it is looking
very three level once and once more and
the kills they started out with a big
aged Ryan young condition Chang's to
jump out of that command throw since he
got hit by a previously this time just
commit to the heavy button and again
it's a similar start up riot the closed
fist means is gonna punch you the open
palm he's gonna grab you but it's very
hard to distinguish between the two in
the moment absolutely now I would expect
nothing less for this to be going to a
game 3 between these two they're both
Titans
they both always consistently I mean
typically at most of these events
they've been making top eight yeah for
sure
of course the kill stage again coming
off that thunderstruck victory Shane's
always performing super well especially
in 2019 he's really coming to his own
one of the premier players in the entire
world for Dragon Ball fighters not just
the EU is one one here and this is for
losers top a qualifier I know that's
hard to believe but shanks did falling
subatomic savers we saw apology man
defeat the kill sage
[Applause]
so one of these guys will not be a copy
[Music]
I think I was actually been told by the
Kelso's there is actually hurt later
here especially if the co-state doesn't
make any Bank off of the sparking that
early and it's already gone yeah it's a
fortune only seven seconds really given
level one sparking here and build much
meaner off of it because he used the
Vantage and now shanks in complete
control snap them out bring in this beam
assist block on the empty long he has a
lot of Gohan experience obviously living
with Nakia watch the fastball clashes
and then go to the end afterwards huge
play from the kill stage okay great
except not the assist there
going into line we want to get Goku out
gone already going just like that and he
takes the opportunity there take it out
they're gonna get blown up for that
level are we gonna see it really
sparking it from shakes yeah yeah I have
to spinning that bar the potential at
least you didn't want to give up the
character but desperate super - gets to
a jump cancel the second hit the oh that
would have been it so hard to recognize
that in a moment
Rolly is running roughshod all over this
team I tried to get the command grabbing
the sky while the key black chase them
down dragon roars we'll do enough damage
the armor theory does not connect lariat
expressed with the rods hat man brawling
is all over the place to age James can't
figure out how to get past the big man
he still living with his girl Hondo all
the unblockable and then hello Wow
despite all that shakes is actually
there look at the first character kill
and it's gonna be on the Brawley he's
gonna go
huge break huge break for shanks right
there well done but still things are
looking rough on his side lots of health
gone yeah get hit by that heat dome on
DP Android 17 not connecting therefore
block wow he actually blocked just in
time right thank yourself walking
forward anticipating the cross up
recognizing the super dashes on though
lock them down the pink ohon exit kill
say it's going to bring out that heavy
17 assists to make sure he can suspend
it just quite yet the blast he didn't
believe in its own anything you would
actually get the ground hit I like the
back off there got to be careful against
this character goes for the love all
he's able to reflect the 17 and system
is what afterwards oh opening there this
is gonna be a lot of damage here who
shanked he wants to bring it down the
great defense here from the kill sage go
through the grab gets blown up for it
Wow great challenge with the kill sage
right there you saw the start over the
command throw not on oh he's got five
bars on back
yeah you can extend this right all the
way through all yes I'll have to get rid
of the Android 18 now we're two
characters apiece that's character to
take out if you're gonna take out one of
shanks his characters but he still does
have that go on even though he is by it
thread level three holy smokes I was so
smart
yeah it's gonna get a good set up after
this what is he gonna do micro walk out
into the auto Powerball huge star for
the kill sage here
[Music]
enough to kill here level one level I'm
gonna get some that blue help back while
dad comes back out and just a go on
hanging on by a thread left here huge
damage all those level ones it literally
took to the last hit to get him now
changes dust down to the pixel Gohan Wow
up he blasts trying to control that
space as best as he can kill him right
now this is so scary for shapes to be in
terrifying he's gonna get hit by the
staggered key blast there you hate to
see it the runt 4 el padre and shortly
love Santa yeah the kills sage able to
secure his spot in top eight looser side
taking down shanks so we felt it both
subatomic savers and the kill stage here
at this tournament I'm sure we're gonna
see shanks at the Spain saga for sure
we'll probably see him at the finals as
well as the Japan saga so shanks is
tournament season is most definitely not
over just yet
absolutely and I just saw a little back
pad hug from fellow EU brother when as
he was coming off the stage you know
giving some love to shanks you know he
made a great run here but that doesn't
mean he news out